[Musica]
puoi vederti con le mani al cielo
arrivare you can you can no vabbè non
c'era la musica tra però ci stava un
sacco siamo sui mandati messaggi
elezione nel momento siamo sul siamo
sulla wii fit che in english madonna che
proprio su mauri fames che sarebbe
questo questa cosa dove c'è una macchina
non chiedetemi questo gioco ma vediamo
insomma guarda l'introduzione si vi
traduco io perché sono una persona che
sa l'inglese devo farlo oltre pivot sly
che just work from come se mi fosse
appena svegliato da un sogno ed dove
stiamo andando
quanto a lungo stavo guidando tutto ciò
che sapevo e che dovevo continuare ad
andare che avrei saputo la mia
destinazione quando l'avrei vista ed ero
pronto ad addormentarmi per iniziare a
sognare ancora non ho capito un punto
sembrava un hotel non sembra solo a the
beguine a ok a si inizia che bello
sarebbe la gente tutti gli oro che dico
ma come mi piace è finito quel tizio
ecco finalmente mi hanno ascoltato e mi
hanno fatto capire come ci è arrivato
quindi questo caso è un po fatto ed è
arrivato qua perché non hp sembra un
hotel e questo non mi sa proprio di un
gene gli hotel c'hanno la scritta come
si chiama con la scritta che c'erano gli
altri sopra le di hotel ci hanno proprio
quella scritta lippi qua non vedo però
ok live view livelli questi giochi
salve c'è anche una persona ma dai nord
dove ci sono persone permesso salve cosa
potrei fare per te ti dai una coca cola
un big mac cosa minchia vuoi che faccia
per te sono entrato non volere una
stanza aperto il bar
vorrei una stanza per cortesia una
stanza ho finito tutte le stanze per
stanotte ma che strano l'hotel mi sembra
talmente bello che porca vacca poco
sorpreso è che abbiamo fini tutte le
stanze bene ragazzi abbiamo
12 non abbiamo pagato una sega perfetto
quindi andiamo nella stanza numero 12
comunque su tripadvisor poi di voto vi
do un voto alto e perché l'hotel fan
poca gare però le stanze le danno gratis
quindi niente male
mi scusi c'è la finestra sbarrata non so
se è un problema c'è lo fate perché ci
sono c'è il demonio per messico
ok allora quella contro daniel va un po
meglio di quanto mi aspettassi
meno male molto carino di spunterà il
demonio tra stanotte e già lì questo
tavolo e per due avanti stavo sognando
un tavolo per due o dei sogni veramente
strani si sia adesso apro le scopro che
questa roba
il bar è aperto grace vuole compagnia la
tua macchina se n'è andata adesso non me
ne frega nulla della macchina perché
grace vuole compagnia quindi let's go
non si rifiuta mai la cernia inventario
amanda è permesso la passera mi aspetta
ad andare al bar
non so dove sia il bar però ci andiamo
penso che sia quello rosa grace and one
mi6 grace
immaginiamo un po pignocca talk man a
noi un uomo va bene e sembra che
qualcosa si stia dando problemi non lo
lasciano già un appuntamento non ho
fatto niente con questo gioco mette
veramente un'inquietudine pazzesca come
se qualcosa mi dovesse saltare addosso
da un momento all'altro orribile però
vabbè se n'è andato l'uomo di prima
porca vacca grace c'è qualcosa qua glock
porca vacca grace sei qua sopra anno
entrano po ovunque vediamo dove senza
uno chiuso senza dove chiuso cos'è sta
roba da ragazzi a noè
va bene la passera e tutto però con un
contegno grace sei qua a grace
ecco la minchia se ci avevo ragione
senti ma questo appuntamento
stiamo già saltando le tappe regia in
questa cda 16
mi sono perso bene questa la mia stanza
e quindi sei nel posto sbagliato e mi
dispiaceva per tv
perché furbata via tanto ti fotto
l'accendino così a random ciao comunque
sei un pò gnocca anche tu spero che
grace e non sia da meno
ma poi c'è un tasto rosso switch dallo
spegnere tutte le luci accendere solo
questa l'ex glover e office molto bene
molto bene
la grace se mica qua
questo non è proprio il posto da grace e
prove spuntano cosa è fighissimo cioè le
tende si spengono con l'eco i pulsanti
ok grace c'è veramente trovare selena
gomez è più facile comunque dobbiamo
trovare sicura voce una chiave stanza 9
aggiunta al tuo inventario che chiave
della stanza da bagno nella stanza 9
carino mio dio quanto casino per trovare
una grace questa stanza è 12 questa è la
mia quindi no no
9 ecco qua sono entrato in una stanza
chiusa quindi non può esserci nessuno
però sigarette no magari non ho ben
capito cosa c'è in sostanza probo vabbè
usciamo ce n'è veramente non ho capito
niente
oh mio dio mi dai una mano a capire cosa
devo fare che c'è una lattina tra
l'altro l'avevo vista faccenda è che a
io posso usare il corso che ho preso
l'accendino o perfetto quindi adesso è
diventata una cosa romantica tu stai lì
dove sei e place ha messo anche lo slip
il talk gray swanson com è un po di
compagnia
poi se le arti qui se ti piace grace
mazzo sei una tipa svelta vedo ciao né
sonora a trovarti dobbiamo passiamo
cambiarci di posto che c'è quel tipo
dietro che veramente brutto mentre parlo
a te c'è quel tipo che mi serve non è
proprio bello sono abbastanza 15 non si
è mai stato libero ok va bene allora
devo venire nella stanza numero ciclo
devo aspettarti ma come cosa sei
mortisia allora non so dove la sera
stanza numero 5 ma ci mette un attimo a
trovarla
questa no questa è esatto sbloccato la
stanza ruolo 5 let's go mortisia e grace
come ti chiami c'è qualcuno qua c'è una
bottiglia grace ai dei cuscini un post
minchi però vabbè grace grace c'è una
stanza nella stanza siamo sicuri che
quel drink era buono che è successo qua
sono caduta grace perché è un telefono
nella doccia
ascoltami gola ma do magg è bene è stato
un po ok grace ma mi devi portare il
proprio in posti così appartati ci
ricordava molto pignocca forse era
l'effetto dell'alcol vabbé ti lascio lì
che bello questo gioco che sta
diventando sembrava troppo facile ciao
devo andare lavati i denti zio devo
andare qua sopra c'è la mia tipa quindi
ci vado
grace amami dove 626 grace se la mia
vita grace ma chi perché contro uomini
nel mio percorso ma chi se ne frega
cosa hai fatto la mia donna grace tease
crescendo un albero in faccia radice
rossa e aggiunto alimentario grace sei
tu va bene ragazzi basta uscire tutto si
risolve nessun problema comunque bella
sta cosa che le camere si collegano dal
sottopassaggio carino questo hotel a un
sacco da offrire ecco il tipo di prima è
sparito questa notizia fa veramente
schifo
ricordatevi ragazzi problema non sono i
ragni quando li vedete problema non li
vedete più ora cav h che posto di brutto
no non è vero non c'è più uscita vabbè
ciao loren ha posto sempre si sveglia
molto presto non osso riuscito a dormire
è aperto il bar sempre aperto va bene
ora vado al bar
grazie ore la stronza perché mi farei
del male però vabbè ciao a grace ciao
grace tutto ok se cercando compagnia
se continuiamo così a vita spiega mi
stai facendo qua nel mezzo del nulla ma
niente guarda abbiamo così tanto in
comune ma mai già dette ste frasi è
tutto un repeat credo che sia così
[Musica]
macché
qualcuno ha capito qualcosa di tutto
questo non ho capito una secca va bene
ragazzi miei spero che il video vi sia
piaciuto è stato chiaro i miei che
imprese sono sempre i limpidi si capisce
bene in tutto quello che faccio però
vabbè se avete delle spiegazioni un po
migliori di quello che ho dato io cioè
io credo di essere all'inferno poi
magari ho sbagliato schietta mano nei
commenti cioè voglio sono curioso di
leggere che cosa starà mica appena
giocato però ok molto simpatica come
situazione ragazzi miei spero che vi sia
piaciuto come mi piace anche sui social
cominciato la descrizione se non solo
così si chiede e noi ci vediamo l'anno
prossimo video dai ragazzi
[Musica]